[Music]
quick speed round tell me your favorite
things about a couple of the
front-runner set Blake Blake was just a
guy right off the bat that I felt
connected to we were just always on the
same wavelength and he kept me laughing
that first night and throughout the
entire journey Colton
Colton good night one I remember just
thinking and how big of a heart he had I
felt like we really connected over that
and he's easy on the eyes
clay clay he is so sweet he addressed he
thought he was a football player but
he's up the stereo stereotypical
football player and he was just so kind
so sweet he's like no one I've ever met
before
mm-hm he's a good one let's talk about
who got your first impression Rose you
said you were smitten Garrett Garrett
yeah I mean fresh out of the minivan I
can't even say limos in minivan I
thought it was cute I liked that Garrett
could be light-hearted and laugh about
the future about being a dad and having
the minivan and then what I really liked
was just the fly-fishing they reminded
me so much of home and reminded me of my
dad and I wanted to give it to somebody
that really stuck out that night who's
the villain Jordan Lincoln what can you
tell us you'll have to find out I mean
it honestly changes week by week
[Music]